polina how are you john how are you life
is good fantastic amazing you good john
i'm great you're good i just i just i
just double and triple checking oh look
there you go
all right
go ahead
i just want to say something to the
people hello you cool cats and kittens
okay all right let's go all right so
janet yellen the u.s treasury secretary
has warned that inflation in the u.s is
quote unacceptably high and said
bringing down rising prices will be
washington's top priority
well i mean she's just stating the
obvious what do you guys think john
shouldn't this have been their top
priority six months ago when they
everyone knew this was coming or 12
months ago or 12 months ago or 18 months
ago when they were 24 months yeah right
i think we all knew this was coming
right yeah one we knew it all was coming
but the other pieces that she said in
her speech which he said is unacceptably
high agreed so
great now that we're admitting that uh
they've previously said it's not
transitory after they thought it was
transitory okay great uh she claims
correctly that the labor market is tight
what that basically means is
unemployment right now is like 3.5 3.6
percent near a historic low before the
pandemic was 3.4 percent so uh that's
good because that means that we've
recovered all of the jobs that we lost
during the pandemic which is a pretty
incredible feat so you get credit for
getting the labor market back
but she also claims in the same speech
that uh the united states is releasing
tons of oil from their strategic
reserves as a way to essentially flood
the market and also they're trying to
put price controls on russian oil so
that they can get energy prices down as
we know gasoline in the united states is
up 60 percent over the last 12 months
some of that is loose monetary policy
some of that supply chain disruptions
and some of that is geopolitical
conflict but at the end of the day they
can
say inflation is high they could say
food is too high they can say gas is too
high they can say this is what we're
doing a b and c they can lay out all the
plants they can do the speeches all that
the average person
only knows when they go to the grocery
store
[ __ ] is more expensive and that's a
problem i have one question in one
comment good question do we think
inflation can get higher
well it definitely could go higher do i
think it's going to go higher um it's a
great question because what we're
already seeing is one core inflation has
started to come down a little bit so you
take out the food and the energy so that
is a positive uh sign and they will
point to and say look inflation's gonna
come down the second thing is uh we've
also seen gasoline prices start to fall
over the last month so if that is a
major contributor that would be good and
the third thing uh that works in their
favor is they're willing to change the
basket of goods they're willing to
switch up how they calculate it and so
even if inflation actually on a real
basis gets higher they can always keep
it under that 10
i think that 10
is a psychological barrier yeah if
similar to taxes once your tax rate goes
over fifty percent people like hold on
man this feels over fifty percent is i'm
working for the government yeah like
right now like literally if your tax
rate is over fifty percent you've been
working for yourself uh for 14 days this
year
because you worked for them up until
june 30th and now you're working for
yourself right so when you think about
um uh kind of 10 inflation high
inflation the difference between 8.5 and
9.1 i don't think many people like
there's like it's high once you cross
over 10 psychological barriers whoa whoa
whoa whoa which they probably should
have done like five percent but i do
think 10 is just because double digits
big big issue eventually it will come
back down right because it just can't
continuously increase like that many
times over and over like year over year
right um it's compounding right now i
can't wait for them to start claiming
victory well if you really think about
what's going on here is last june june
2021 inflation was 5.4
so fr if you went to sleep in june of
2020 and woke up june of 2021 kind of
like a opened your eyes and said you
know what's going on you're like damn
prices are 5.4 higher but then if you
fell back asleep and you woke up last
june uh this past june uh of 2022 and
looked around you're like damn prices
are 9.1 percent higher than they were
last june but if you start to compound
this that means that goods in june of
2020 to june of 2022 are up double
digits
that is what we're now experiencing is
the 9.1 percent is on top of the 5.4
from last year so now you're gonna get
in a situation where at what point do
they get it back down to two percent we
could next year they could get inflation
down and it could be five percent next
june and if that was the case you'd say
from 2020 to 2021 5.4 2821 to 2022 9.1
and then 2022 to 2023 5
that would be a nightmare um they're
going to claim victory the second that
the number goes down if it goes from 8.1
to 8 they're going to claim victory they
uh they definitely are going to claim
victory when it when it goes below eight
percent that that's the threshold eight
percent of what we're winning
what's the next thing wait my comment oh
god
my comment was i was watching the speech
of janet yellen i was like why are there
palm trees behind her like where the
hell is she and apparently there's a
finance ministers meeting in bali
interesting that they do a lot of
conferences there really
yeah i mean
yeah fun fact
yeah
that's a palm tree okay i bet you it's
really hot okay so jp morgan chase said
that second quarter profit slumped as
the bank built reserves for the bad loan
for bad loans by 428 million and
suspended share buybacks but but what i
thought was interesting here is jamie
dimon
said that the u.s economy continues to
grow
and both the job market and consumer
spending remain healthy
but he said geopolitical tension high
inflation waning consumer confidence the
uncertainty about how high rates have to
go in the never before seen quantitative
tightening and their effects on global
liquidity combined with the war in
ukraine and its harmful effect on global
energy and food prices are very likely
to have negative consequences on the
global economy sometime down the road
there are so many problems in the world
right now like that was a word salad of
a sentence he said people love to point
at bank ceos and yell and scream like
they're idiots they're stupid they're
not doing this whatever especially in
the bitcoin and crypto world where like
oh they don't understand technology i've
done it everyone's done it they're like
easy uh kind of uh targets for uh the
meaning on the internet
but they have immense amounts of data
they have huge research teams and
analysts
that they can rely on and what he said
there is probably one of the most
coherent analysis of what is happening
in the world which is there are a number
of data points which we've now seen uh
treasury secretary yellen we've seen
jamie dimon a number of others point to
employment we still have a pretty strong
labor market now it could get worse but
right now it's pretty strong
but there are also problems in the world
and things like the geopolitics uh the
the quantitative easing quantitative
tightening all these different things
even simple things like they're raising
interest rates when the economy
contracted in q1
when did we ever see this happen before
is this more like a 1980s scenario this
is more like a 1970s is this more like
japan or is this more like some past
time in america there's all these folks
trying to figure it out and what you can
really summarize it all on is the
economy is a very very complex machine
and no one can predict it
no one
what do you think john
yeah i mean he hit it on the head right
like you have to understand this stuff
like these are very intelligent
individuals but they're taking an
educated guess right the economy as you
said is very complex and it's very
unpredictable as we've seen the last two
years you just never know what's going
to happen uh so it's hard to just stamp
it and say i'm going we're going with
this plan we're never going to change it
this is how we're thinking as people
know things evolve over time right he's
just changing his opinion on what he
thinks will happen in the future uh and
he's leading an organization that
matters a lot right uh the loan stuff to
me uh keeping money in for bad loans
just don't make bad loans loan to good
creditors right people now have higher
credit scores than ever when they're
borrowing money well so and this is very
nuanced and i'm going to make some
generalizations here but to help people
understand when banks make loans they
in their models account for we're going
to lose money on a couple of loans they
built a portfolio of loans hey something
goes wrong with this one we have 10
others that make up for it right it's no
different than venture capital uh or
anything else where a portfolio provides
you protection from ones that could go
wrong and the whole key is risk
management and so when you head towards
bad times remember during covid more and
more businesses failed than normal there
was a spike in that uh polina is yawning
because she's like oh my god this is so
no this is detailed this is the big
short what are those things called the
things
the stacks you know the the
jenga no
okay but you're talking about like the
bad loans but i'm talking about the bad
mortgages in with the good ones what are
they called cds yes uh so the whole idea
is that you basically end up having uh
these loan books and when you go into
bad times more loans than normal will be
default or things will go wrong and so
they have to account for they have to
prepare for so they do they say hey
maybe we should put more cash on our
balance sheet have a stronger
uh have a stronger balance sheet then
on top of that they also are not doing
share buybacks uh they're pausing it
share buybacks which lots of people love
to hate on is a tax efficient way to
return capital back to shareholders
instead of doing a dividend you do a
share buyback it pushes the stock up
there are
bad incentives that go along with that
but
why are they pausing share buybacks so
they have more cash they're holding
their cash on their balance sheet and
they're saying we don't know what's
going to happen
strong balance sheet get cash flow up as
high as we can be prepared for good
times or bad times but go they're almost
like saying like we're going into battle
and if you go into battle what do you do
you just
rally the troops
their troops are dollars that's what
they're doing
all right what's up with rent all right
the average monthly rent for a manhattan
apartment surpassed five thousand
dollars for the first time ever that's
the highest ever it's been and that's
the average rent
right like john you're good
i thought i was getting screwed in miami
5k for rent to live in a shoebox in
manhattan that's just not sustainable
yeah
but they're saying that it could go even
higher in the fall
of course well right now is the time
that people are moving in right this is
traditionally people graduate from
colleges or schools or whatever and the
summer is that transition time where
people get new leases and rents
that's why the average is going to keep
going up is because you're going to get
the june july and august although all
those aspiring actors journalists
writers how are they affording five
thousand dollar rent are they sharing it
with like seven other people no they're
not what do you mean that's why
brooklyn's so popular no but
hoboken no hoboken yeah i mean like it's
not any cheaper it's pushing out well
it's definitely cheaper it's just it's
not
more affordable again this is real [ __ ]
right what we are watching is we are
watching a whole bunch of different
cities
real estate prices rents are going up
and wages are not growing at the same
rate wait this is really funny somebody
said at the end a broker at sirhan said
at the end of the day they want to be in
new york even some of the families that
went to miami are coming back of course
some people are going to go back 100
percent uh but also there's a lot of
people who are graduating college at
john's point they're looking around the
country and they're saying to themselves
where should i move and guess what
they're not moving to new york they're
not moving to miami they're not moving
to austin they're not moving to san
francisco and they're not moving to la
they're going to places like uh
nashville and they're saying to
themselves oh i heard nashville's got
parties i heard it's cheap and i heard
there's a couple of tech companies where
i could work remote
and so that's what's going to play out
here now is people are starting to make
decisions based on affordability and
what you're likely to see is that
there's plenty of people in new york
city
specifically in manhattan that will say
to themselves
i'm not going to live in manhattan i'm
instead going to go to brooklyn i'm
going to go to uh park slope i'm going
to go to hoboken i'm going to go
somewhere outside i'm going to go to
rochester i'm going to go live on long
island thank you for your knowledge and
i'm going to get a way to get into the
city but i'm not actually going to live
in the city because the average runs 5
000. but do we think yes it's an influx
of people moving back but do we think
that inflation also plays a part
this is all inflation in my opinion what
changed in new york city
literally more real estate no what
changed in new york city real estate in
the last two years
politics
well i would argue that uh more people
want to leave which should bring the
prices down yeah right because of the
politics and then you say crime and all
like you lay it all in new york is
probably less quality of living right
now than it was three years ago before
the pandemic and so in that case if it's
less quality of living less people
should want to work there or live there
and work there and if there's less
people that want to live and work there
and less companies are requiring you to
live there then that means there's less
demand if there's less demand that means
the prices should be lower but instead
they're higher but there is not less
demand i think that's the demand will
always be there for new york city we
just saw a pandemic where there was a
million reasons to move out of the city
or live people elsewhere and people did
but now they're flooding back for a
reason because those i don't think
they're flooding back but i really
haven't seen people i think it's young
people
mentioned of course but those young
people don't have the spending power
that the older people have and what
you're gonna see is that yes young
people will move there look if i was 22
years old and i was graduating college
right i just graduated and you said
where should you move new york would
probably be top of the list you know why
it's a cool ass city you can go party
your face off with all your friends
there's lots of job opportunities you
can do all this stuff
but when somebody calls me up and
they're 40 years old like i got a family
what should i do
new york isn't even on the list
yeah because they have different
considerations and so naturally what
you're seeing is yes there is some
demand but the demand for new york real
estate has from the last numbers i saw
have not reached pre-pandemic levels
there's still less demand it's monetary
policy that's driving this and people
are having to get out of cash and get
into hard assets it says betting wars
are now routine for rentals one bedrooms
are going for six thousand dollars
i've seen videos of lines middle of the
day open houses that stretch down the
block you can tell me all the anecdotes
you want in the world i just look at the
data the data says that we are not uh as
of two months ago unless something
changed the last two months
uh we were not at the pre-pandemic
levels uh in terms of demand
yeah we'll see
okay
all right ready let's do it so this is
very interesting twitter is testing
custom timelines and the first one is
about the bachelorette it's a new
feature that will show users custom
timelines built by developers that will
merge tweets and other media around
specific themes or interests based on
you know the content they pull from
accounts and hashtags and stuff and so
they're testing it with the bachelorette
and i'm guessing they're doing that
because the bachelorette is a live event
that you watch every like monday at 8pm
and people like to tweet about it as
they watch so i think this is a perfect
use case what do you think john what do
you think
uh i mean everyone's gonna have this
eventually every social media platform
will implement some version of this
right to give you a personalized
experience to where you can see news in
the manner that you want whether that's
the way you want it or the way they
perceive that you want it uh you're
going to get that headline right they
they may have a toggle option to turn it
off and on or whatever it may be but
like everyone's going to have this
eventually i think i think it's a great
idea because you know how right now on
twitter there's like a news section on
the right and whenever i watch the
bachelorette i click on that and i see
what people are saying but i guess this
is just like
it'll it'll automatically populate if it
knows that those are my interests every
monday they're already tracking you
across everything
i don't know how i feel about this why
personalized headlines or timelines
timelines
i mean like i see the value of it but
also at the same time like kind of you
know like the source material but your
timeline's already sourced right now but
you can make it reverse chronological
can you yeah you can go and you can uh
change it no not chronologically i'm
saying like the tweets that are pulled
in for me are different than the tweets
that are pulled in for you based on
followers likes like they're they
haven't happened what i'm saying is you
can remove that you can go and you can
switch it and and then you can make it
reverse chronological so when you're on
there twitter says we're not going to
tell you which one's at the top which
one's at the bottom it's just what's the
last tweet from somebody you follow
anthony i've seen you follow hashtags or
like when you watch like a sporting
event you want to see what people are
saying oh i i will go look at them
sometimes but it's usually not because
i'm trying to augment the experience
it's because something happened
right like they're like i know there's a
thing or i saw it trending or whatever
isn't this easier instead of you trying
to search on twitter dude i like stuff
on instagram and twitter and all these
places just to have more things that are
similar come in my feed sometimes i
don't even like it and i'm like i like
the idea and i want to bring it in what
is space debris only because we got a
little love we gotta we gotta get moving
here all right you guys see me here
all right got deadlines
this study published in nature astronomy
on monday says that there's a 10 chance
rocket debris will kill somebody on
earth this decade
that's scary i mean ten percent i would
love to know how they come over here how
do they come up with ten percent
building
now
they used more than 30 years of data
from a public satellite catalog to
calculate the potential risk that
uncontrolled rocket body re-entries have
on human life in the next 10 years
10 is a psychological barrier now i'm
saying
but it's from rockets it's not like
actual space debris no no rocket debris
yeah that's what i'm saying it's from
humans sent it up and then coming down
it would hurt somebody yes uh which is
very different than like an asteroid's
gonna hit her yeah that's the biggest
scary thing is we're the ones that put
that stuff into space and it's gonna
hurt people not that it's just natural
yeah yeah it makes sense we put cars on
the road they hurt people well as we
like launch more rockets and of course
you would hope it would become safer but
unlikely god i really hope that i'm not
the one online do you have any last
words for the people
be kind to your friends throw it back